imagine this it's summer vacation and
you're a kid you and your friends are
playing in the woods near your
neighborhood just like you've been doing
most days during the break from school
one day you spot a tree house it's not
that high off the ground and it's very
simply built from leaves grass and
scraps of wood you and your friends are
curious so you decide to check it out
upon investigation you find a kid in
there he says his name is billy and this
is his tree house you don't recognize
him from school but you figure he just
must be new in town he asks if he can
join your group and wanting to be nice
to the new kid you tell him okay you
spend the rest of the day playing with
him games like hide and seek tag and red
rover until it's time for everyone to go
home for dinner strangely billy doesn't
seem to leave he just stays in his tree
house for the rest of the week playing
with billy and his treehouse become a
regular fixture of your daily routine
but oddly enough he never comes to hang
out at any of your houses and you never
seem to see him anywhere else but in the
woods one day however he decides to
invite one of your friends amy to hang
out with him at the tree house alone you
think nothing of it but after that point
you never see billy again it's a couple
of weeks before you and your friends see
amy again and when you do she appears
off somehow she seems to be spending a
lot of time in that tree house billy has
disappeared but you and amy and the rest
of the kids keep meeting up to play
together in the woods one day amy pulls
you aside she wants you to come meet
with her tomorrow at the tree house
alone
this is typically how an scp-974
infestation begins with a mysterious new
kid inviting a group of friends to hang
out in this crudely made treehouse but
as you might have guessed this kid isn't
a kid he's scp-974
a carnivorous monster that only looks
like a human child it can live on small
woodland animals but its preferred prey
is kids between the ages of 6 and 12
taking the phrase you are what you eat
to the next level the entity will
install itself in an area with a
sufficient amount of trees in proximity
to a decent population of children who
will then construct a crude tree house
to serve as its nest and begin
befriending groups of between two and
five children the creature will engage
in normal outdoor games and allow its
new friends to come and go as they
please building the trust of its
newfound playmates but then after about
a week it will select its victim
scp-974 will single out one member of
the group and invite them to the
treehouse alone whether they accept or
deny the invitation is irrelevant
because this is the point where
scp-974 will strike subduing and then
devouring that child after doing so the
creature will disappear from the area
going into a state of hibernation for
roughly 12 days during that time it goes
through a period of metamorphosis
transforming from whoever it looked like
before into an exact likeness of the
child it just consumed
scp-974 will continue this cycle of
selecting and catching prey until there
are no children left in the surrounding
area while it's initially friendly to
children scp-974
has an intense fear of any older human
beings the mere presence of a person
older than 13 is enough to trigger the
creature's fight-or-flight response and
it will run away if it sees any adults
coming when running isn't an option
scp-974 will resort to violence to
defend itself despite its looks scp-974
is much stronger faster and more
resistant to damage than a child and it
has been known to completely rip adults
apart in situations where it felt
threatened and cornered
scp-974 does not appear to be affected
by bullets or striking weapons and the
only reliable way to put down an
instance seems to be with fire when
infestations are discovered in the wild
the normal scp foundation protocol is to
attempt to capture the creature but if
deadly force is required
agents will set fire to the creature's
nest and a portion of the surrounding
area until it has been confirmed dead
before covering up the destruction as
the result of a regular forest fire the
scp foundation was able to capture one
instance of scp-974
and place it in containment hoping that
having one in captivity would provide
insight into the creature's origins it
was placed in a lightly wooded enclosure
at zoological reserve site-16 where it
immediately started constructing
multiple tree house nests from the plant
life it found initially the containment
of scp-974 involved offering the
creature live human prey once every
three months a group of four children
would be brought in in accordance with
protocol 12 the children would be given
room and board in on-site barracks and
encouraged to explore the enclosure and
play with scp-974
if 974 had not selected a victim within
five days the group of children would be
sent away and a new group would be
introduced this system worked for a few
years but as you might expect the ethics
committee had a problem with the
practice of offering up live children to
a deadly anomaly now as of january 1st
2015 the team at zoological reserve's
site 16 are no longer able to evoke
protocol 12 in order to acquire children
attempts to use another scp
scp-1680 a collection of clones of a
missing eight-year-old boy failed as
scp-974 refused to eat them the
procedures then changed to only allow
small animals to be introduced into the
enclosure as prey while it might seem
like this was a good idea that would
stop
scp-974 from killing any more children
like a lot of seemingly good changes to
containment procedures in the foundation
this well-intentioned move would
ultimately have deadly consequences
scp-9s
at first seemed to behave normally
despite being denied its favorite food
but then on august 16 2015 while on
their weekly sweep of the enclosure
patrol teams found that 974 had
destroyed all of the tree houses it had
built in its time and containment the
scp itself was also nowhere to be found
there was something new in the enclosure
though a small oval of disturbed soil a
geological team was called in and
through ground penetrating radar it was
found that there was a humanoid figure
buried there curled up in a fetal
position this couldn't be scp-974
could it the figure was much too long
and thin to be anything resembling a
human child but it had to be
scp-974 it was the only living thing in
the enclosure the scientists were
intrigued and they theorized that the
scp might have entered a new life stage
further scans were conducted over the
next 10 days during that time the
creature never moved from its position
though it did continue to grow it seemed
like it was absorbing nutrients from the
surrounding soil the team decided to
exhume the creature to examine it when
they dug it up they found that scp-974
had stretched out now measuring 220
centimeters in length and weighing just
37.4 kilograms it had no features or
orifices of any kind anywhere on its
body and its now pale white skin was
covered in some kind of sticky mucus
that when examined was found to contain
a previously undiscovered enzyme the
creature was alive but barely it wasn't
breathing and its heartbeat was
extremely slow almost to the point of
being undetectable
scp-974 was examined for an additional
four weeks after which it died and was
sent for dissection some of the
scientists and researchers at zoological
site 16 were disappointed to hear about
974's death as vicious and feral as the
creature was they developed a certain
fondness for it and its many tree houses
luckily it wouldn't be too much longer
until a new specimen was obtained on
october 16 2016 a group of no less than
seven instances of
scp-974 were discovered near a major
american city the containment team was
forced to kill six of the anomalies in
the attempts to capture them but one
instance survived and was taken to
zoological site-16 as was mandated the
area was burned and foundation
counterintelligence disseminated a cover
story about a forest fire caused by an
improperly extinguished campfire the new
scp-974 was like the original one placed
in the enclosure and denied human prey
also like the first one this 974 buried
itself after being denied its preferred
meals for several months the decision
was made to leave the scp underground
longer than the first instance to see
what it might become if this
developmental stage wasn't interrupted
on january 25th 2017
the creature finally dug itself free
from the earth now designated scp-974-a
it was far more aggressive than any
instance of 974 had ever been before as
soon as it was free from the dirt it
made a beeline straight for the nearest
monitoring station it ripped the roof
off and tore the 16 members stationed
there to shreds in just 90 seconds when
the response team arrived 15 minutes
later only 12 percent of the human
remains were able to be recovered but
strangely enough it at first seemed like
one of the team had been spared george's
stone one of the monitoring team was
severely injured but apparently in a
stable condition disoriented she
approached the response team begging for
assistance and urging them to take her
out of the enclosure but the team was
skeptical they knew that scp-974 could
become an exact copy of any child it
consumed so it followed that the fully
grown scp-974-a
might be able to copy adults they asked
georgia questions in order to confirm
her identity but she was unable to
answer them having being found out
scp-974 still mimicking georgia attacked
the response team they'd been armed with
flamethrowers but unfortunately on top
of its resistance to damage the adult
form of 974 didn't seem to be afraid of
or harmed by
fire the team was at a loss for how to
kill this thing or even subdue it long
enough to get out safely
scp-974-a was tearing through the
members of the team like they were made
out of paper thinking quickly one member
of the response team a guard named
emilio pulled out one of his standard
issue foundation hand grenades when
scp-974-8 came at him he pulled the pin
and holding the grenade shoved his arm
into the creature's open mouth while the
explosion destroyed emilio's arm it
didn't even break the skin of
scp-974-a however it did result in
serious damage to its internal organs
which finally killed it following its
death an autopsy was conducted revealing
enough about the creature that a new
file of effective methods of
extermination was able to be created
after this event the protocols for
scp-974 containment were completely
overhauled any instances of scp-974
seen in the wild are to be killed as
quickly as possible more disturbingly
though the ethics committee rescinded
their previous decision and any
instances of 974 that are brought into
containment are to be provided with
human prey again letting scp-974 kill
children might not be a very humane way
of keeping it contained but given how
much more aggressive and hard to kill
this scp's adult form is any option that
stops the creature's metamorphosis from
happening is likely the best option in
the long run so remember if you're ever
out in the woods and see a crudely
constructed tree house perhaps think
twice about how innocent it is there
could be something hungry lurking inside
now go check out our playlist with the
entire tale of scp-5000 the suit for an
epic saga about a foundation gone bad
and one man's quest to find the truth